[Music]
that's right it's Missy's world and
we're all just living in it Missy
misdemeanor Elliott is joining the ranks
of artists such as Britney Spears
Beyonce and JT in taking home the MTV
video Vanguard Award at this year's VMAs
she has worked her way to the top and
will be the first female rapper to
receive the prestigious award
ét is taking a look back at Queen
Missy's greatest moments aside from
holding the record for only female
rapper to have six studio albums go
platinum Missy has continuously given us
hit after hit in 2001 Elliott received
her first Grammy Award for Best Rap
performance for get your freak on a
track from the album Missy so addictive
I think probably with my words they come
across tough but anybody who meets me
I'm like a fun person I like to laughing
and play all day and well we still can't
quite decode the lyrics
Missy collected another Grammy for her
unforgettable 2002 hits take you back to
old school it's a lot of fun make you
want to dance party whatever
Missy's 2005 album the cook book
contains the Grammy winning single that
can still be heard around the world
[Music]
make you do a double-take
recently Missy's been hitting some of
the biggest stages she teamed up with
Katy Perry at the 2015 Super Bowl for an
epic performance I can't even explain
that feeling I've done a lot of shows
but that was a different energy and when
she wasn't losing control for over 100
million viewers Missy joined Michelle
Obama on carpool karaoke where they
talked all things girl power
[Applause]
over the world we feel blessed to have
Missy on this song blessed to be here
Michelle later surprised Missy with a
video message at her January 2019
induction to the Songwriters Hall of
Fame so Missy I wanna thank you for all
of your trailblazing ways thank you not
just for sharing your gift with the
world but for being an advocate for so
many people out there
I'm thankful humble I'm grateful to be
up here with so many geniuses in this
room I met so many people that I looked
up to and still look up to as
songwriters and producers and in June of
that same year
Missy received an honorary degree from
the Berklee College of Music for her
lasting impact in reshaping the
landscape and culture of hip-hop R&B and
pop it is my pleasure to present
Berkeley's honorary doctorate of music
degree to Missy Elliott you have come
too far to quit and I never gave up and
I don't want y'all to give up and I want
to say that I love y'all I thank y'all
so much I'm so sorry that I'm a crybaby
but I'm about the word is this cap and
gown in the shower all my next videos
everywhere I go so don't hold it against
me thank y'all so much I love you
she's collected over 300 nominations and
70 Awards the MTV Moonman is just the
latest for Missy to add to her
collection y'all can stop me there